a couple years ago I was in Ohio
at a shopping mall
an old white lady this is true she was
she was following me around the mall
which sounds paranoid but I'm sure she
was following me
lady too you ever see a woman with lines
on her face that just tell you like even
if she smiled it looked like it would
hurt the muscles in her face
I knew she was following me because she
was at places that had nothing to do
with her I'd be looking around like what
is this old [ __ ] doing in GameStop and
Foot Locker and all the places I like to
go
every time I see it she just be looking
me on me
and eventually I forgot about him so
then after I'm shopping I go all the way
to the back of the parking lot and park
all the way in the back and as soon as I
open my car door I hear a voice go David
Chappelle
just like that I didn't even have to
look I knew it was hurt
and I look back and showing up there she
was that face
be honest with you she probably wasn't
even that old
she's probably around my age
but she was a white woman this this
[ __ ] looked terrible
kept my cool I was nice I said hello
Miss
and she didn't say anything back all she
said was I watch your comedy
I said uh-oh
and then she says it's true she goes
sounds to me
like you hate
women
I said well you know what Miss
it's art
and you're free to interpret this art
however you'd like but I can tell you as
the maker of this art that I don't
believe that I feel that way
and she said well I think and I said
shut up [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up
before I kill you and put you in the
trunk ain't nobody around here
[Applause]
I'm just kidding I didn't say that
foreign
I felt that way but that's not what I
said
I was more clever than that you know
what I said and this is exactly what I
said I said Miss before you finish that
statement let me ask you a question
where did you see me
did you buy a ticket to a concert I did
I doubt that
or or or maybe you watched one of my
specials on Netflix
or or
did I follow you to your car and do my
Act
she said what I said keep it in the
comment section this is real life Tata
and then I drove off you can see it you
ever have this happen this is how
confusing it is this this is the
practical application what I'm talking
about like a guy be out just having a
lot guys you be at a club but all right
he's kicking with your boys and and a
girl walks by and man she looks good she
looks good not good in that classical
way
I mean you know I'm talking good like
she got half her ass hanging out her
skirt
her titties are all mashed together
popping out the top of her turtleneck
and [ __ ]
[Applause]
and he was your buddies right you with
your buddies you got a couple drinks in
you and your secret like this you might
try to talk to it this might not come
out right now I don't know what you're
saying
the girl got Spanish oh oh wait a minute
wait a minute
just because I'm dressed this way
does not
make me a [ __ ]
[Applause]
which is true
gentlemen that is true just because they
dress a certain way doesn't mean they
are a certain way don't ever forget it
but ladies you must understand that that
is [ __ ] confusing
his hands
now that would be like me Dave Chappelle
the comedian walking around the streets
in a cop uniform
somebody might run up on me oh thank God
officer help us come on they're over
here help us
oh
just because I'm dressed this way
and make me a police officer
you understand what I'm saying
I was like all right lady bye
fine you are not a [ __ ]
but you are wearing a horse uniform I'll
tell you that something
thank you
another time about six years ago there
was a lesbian woman that that tried to
sell a story about me to TMZ thank
goodness TMZ could see right through the
Sham of that story
this woman claimed that I beat her up in
a nightclub because she was a lesbian
that is [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] I didn't even know he was a woman
thank God TMZ didn't believe that
because I did beat the [ __ ] out of I'm
not gonna lie
it was her fault I had no choice
I came in the club minding my own
business and a woman came up to me she
goes oh my God Dave Chappelle and I was
just being reciprocally nice hey Miss
how are you blah blah blah benign talk
nothing to it and all of a sudden
it's lesbian fellow step between us
hey [ __ ] that's my girl I said yo yo my
man back up like that
she ain't backing up all [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's my girl I said bro you're gonna
have to give me three feet like this
she said stop
stop command [ __ ] I'm a woman I
said what
[Applause]
and then I look deep in this nigga's
cheekbones
I said oh my God you are a woman
it's too much for me to even wrap my
mind around but I'll tell you what I
unballed my fist immediately and I
softened my pasta so that she would know
she's in no danger I even changed the
tone of my voice
I said Softly
sweetly like a pimp might say
[ __ ] I'm about to slap the [ __ ] out of
you
I should have done it
oh I wish I didn't say that she dropped
that foot back Boop she was in a perfect
Southpaw stance her shoulders were
angled correctly her head moving was
good I said oh no
this [ __ ] box is for Real
she's a little wild hook at me and I saw
it coming from yesterday so I slipped it
like this
[Music]
I had no choice
I had to go to work
I let that jab go you should see me go
[ __ ]
I tenderize them titties like chicken
cutlets
I whooped the toxic masculinity out of
that [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry ladies I just I got a [ __ ]
me too headache y'all's killing me right
now
it's really [ __ ] tough to watch
what's going on you know ladies I said
it in my last special and I got a lot of
trouble for this I told you you were
right
but the way you're going about it is not
going to work but I'm biased I said it
Louis CK was a very good friend of mine
before he died in that terrible
masturbation accident
and it was his room he read the story he
was masturbating in his own room that's
where he supposed to masturbate and then
he said hey everybody I'm gonna pull my
dick out nobody ran for the door and
like that they all just kind of hung out
like I wonder if this guy is serious
and he came on his own stomach there it
is
what is the threat
have any women ever seen a guy that just
came on his own stomach this is the
least threatening [ __ ] the Earth
has ever seen
all you see is shaming him facing
come dripping down like pancake butter
[Applause]
he didn't do anything that you can call
the police for I dare to try call the
police on him hello please yes I am I am
on the other line with comedian Louis CK
and I think that he is masturbating
while I'm on the phone
you know what the police are going to
say in Atlanta
what are you guys talking about
um
[Applause]
Caitlyn Jenner whom I've met wonderful
person Caitlyn Jenner
was voted Woman of the Year her first
year as a woman ain't that something
beat every [ __ ] in Detroit she's better
than all of you
never even had a period ain't that
something
oh I'd be mad as [ __ ] if I was a woman
I'd be mad if I was me if I was in a bet
or you wouldn't then like in the winter
for [ __ ] of the year
Eminem My Name
the only thing and I society that
bothers me the most is the way that men
and women don't get along no more
that's really what's bugging me about it
men and women [ __ ] don't get along like
I hear women say this all the time I
know a lot of your sister be like
chivalry is dead don't you don't y'all
feel that way like men aren't gentlemen
anymore
that's right chivalry is dead and women
killed it
[Applause]
as a fundamental difference in the way
we're going to see things we're not
going to see eye out on this issue we
just now our test in life are different
a woman's test in life is material
a man's test in life is a woman
Now by test I mean it those are the
things that we desire men have nice cars
not because they like nice cars because
they know women like nice cars
that's how it goes because men are
Hunters
and the cars debate
and a woman comes and says ooh nice
Porsche gotcha [ __ ]
that's how it is
that's true come on man you go to a
woman's house or house be comfortable
and [ __ ] women love comfortable
surroundings so they can get comfortable
surroundings let me tell you something
if a man can [ __ ] a woman in a cardboard
box he wouldn't buy a house
[Applause]
but that's still now where chivalry got
killed chivalry got killed by the
feminist movement on the magazines that
got women going crazy because women got
too much advice about men from other
women
and they don't know what the [ __ ] they
talking about
[Applause]
and it's true
I see this [ __ ] in the magazines I don't
read them but I'll be seeing the cover I
look at everybody in the grocery store
fellas he looked one of the magazines
like what is this and it's gonna cover a
hundred ways to please your man by some
lady
get out of here
ain't no hundred way that list is four
things long just suckers dick papers
balls and then fix them a sandwich and
don't talk so much and everything
happens foreign
[Applause]